this has been a long and challenging day
that at the end of it I'm pleased to
have received the backing of my
colleagues in tonight's ballot whilst
I'm grateful for that support a
significant number of colleagues did
cast a vote against me
and I've listened to what they said
following this but pilots we now need to
get on with the draws of delivering
grexit for British people and building a
better future for this country a
breakfast that delivers on the votes
that people gain that brings back
control of our money our borders and our
laws that protects job security and the
Union that brings the country back
together rather than entrenching
division that must start here in
Westminster with politicians on all
sides coming together at acting in the
national interest for my part I've heard
what the House of Commons said about the
Lord and Island backstop and when I go
to the European Council tomorrow I will
be seeking legal and political
assurances that will explain the
concerns that members of parliament have
on that issue but while delivering
brexit is important we also need to
focus on the other issues that people
feel the vital to them that matter to
them today today the issues that we came
into politics to deal with building a
stronger economy delivering first-class
public services building the homes that
families need we owe it to the people
who put us here to put their priorities
first so here is our renewed mission
delivering the breakfast that people
voted for bringing the country back
together and building a country that
truly works for everyone